[拍手]
プレイ今日1
盛り上がったところでいきなり昔話なんですけど
a 今から40年くらいはいいですね
私が兄弟に入った時
先生からよく言われた言葉がありました
それはアホなこと星ということでしたね
もちろん勉強しなくてもいいなんて言ってません
勉強するのは当然で勉強しないとたいもらえませんから
でも
ちゃんと勉強せえと言われた曲はあまりありません
で勉強したからといって p
特に褒められるようなふう子もありませんでした
でも
アホなこと星という言葉は
いろんな先生から言われた曲があります
当時この言葉の意味は私にもよくわかりませんでした
一つわかりやすい
こっちの言葉の意味としては
真実は思いもよらないところにある
だから真面目に考えてもその真実には生き当たらないということだと思います
実際ノーベル賞のようにですね大きな発明
大きな発見は
間違いや
それから失敗の中から生まれることも多いのでこれは一理あります
でも
これにはもう少し深い意味があると思っています
それは
朝花知識を捨てて
心の声を聞けということです
人間妙な知識があると
賢くフルメーター振る舞いたくなります
でもそんなのは所詮人間の浅知恵です
人間には本来生物として
生きていく野生の本土あります
一旦知識を捨てるつまり阿呆になって
心もそういう
ギャ生の感性を研ぎ富済ませということだと思っているんです
せっかく獲得した知識を捨てるなんてもったいない
そんな無駄なことをせずに
これまでの知識を有効に生かして
効率的に
行動すべきだと思うかもしれませんこれだけコンピューターでなんでもできる時代です
から
でもそれをすべてに適用するのは不可能です
なぜなら
世の中カオスだからです
カオスを日本語に訳すと混沌という言葉になります
混沌というと
まったく制御不能で
意味不明の状態を想像するかもしれませんが必ずしもそうでもありません
一見規則的で厳密にメールようなものでもカオスになることがあります
皆さん計算機はいつも正しい答えを出すと思っているんじゃないでしょうか
ここでちょっとひとつの計算をしてみたいと思います
今物の電卓てですね簡単な計算お願いします
2乗して匂いという計算を繰り返すのです出てきた結果を
また同じ計算繰り返します
でどんな電卓で計算しても同じになると思うかも知れ
って今左ししたんですね
値が出ています今のところすべて揃います
水色のフィーナです
たしてい
脱落します
兄も脱落します
[音楽]
まだやっと沿ってますな
次は黄色です
[音楽]
はい
全部バラバラになっちゃいました
同じ計算を36回繰り返しただけです
こういう計算をカオスと言いません
で計算機の計算にもですねごくわずかな誤差があります
彼はその世界ではそのごくわずかな誤差が
将来大きく左右するんです
でそれをバタフライ効果と呼びます
1960年代カオスを発見した
エドワードローレンツは
有薗さ僕にチョウチョ1匹飛んでるかどうかを計算するかどうかでニューヨークに嵐が
来るかどうかを決まるとこういったことから
バタフライ効果という名前がつきました
もともとロレンツは勉強法を研究していてカオスを発見したんです
日々の天気は典型的なカオスです
勉強法では1週間予報しか出さないんですがそれは今のバタフライ効果のためにそれ
以上当たらないからです
でも所詮誤差の話ですから
もっと正確に計算をして2週間以上の計算が予報ができると思うかもしれません
原理的にはできます
でもそのためには
制度に by つまり桁数を2倍にしたければなりません
例えば
今外はですね12.5どうだとします
2倍の精度で計算するためにはですねその拳気温を12.5289ぐらいまで
図らなければならない
それだけ正確に図ろうと思うと皆さん息を止めなきゃ
今日もかかっちゃいますか
で
みんな息を止めて正確に測定をしてめでたく2週間予報を出した暁にはですね皆さん
予定通りに息をして予定通りにくしゃみをしてないと2週間予報はくるんです
今を笑うところです
皆さん笑ってくれなかったのに周回送りました
もう1回やり直し
つまり
彼はその世界ではですね原理的に計算可能に見えることでも現実的には絶望的に難しい
ことになってしまいます
ここで大事なのは
2週間先1か月先の天気予報は無理でも
明日の天気はそこそこ当たるということです
明日の天気がわかればいや今日の天気がわかれば明日の天気がわかる
それを見つけた人類は偉いんですそれが人類の英知です
だから人間は計画的に行動できるし
最後3災害を未然に防ぐこともできます
そして原理的に明日の天気がわかればあさっての天気がわかる
安里の天気がわかれば明々後日がわかるというふうに未来永劫ずーっと先のことが
わかるはずなんですがそこは皆さんが期待するようなわけにはいかない
皆さんの期待のはるか手前で破綻します
それがハウスです
で
そういう
それでもですね生物はそういう何が起こるか分からないかをその世界を30何を9年間
た
生き延びてきています
そもそも天気予報なんてしなくても
西野生の本能で生きています
生物はそういうカオスに対応する何か作戦持っているのでしょうか
多分その一つは
数うちゃ当たる作戦です
10万個くらいある数の子の中で
多分生き残るのは意識です
確率は低くてもどこかに行ける道が
それをひたすら
探っています
もう一つは多分野生の完成です
強さ楽しさをこう記しになる
そういう感覚はおそらく生物の生存に必要な感覚なんだろうと思います
怠惰の性質も過度な緊張を回避する
生物の本能かもしれません
そういう感性に従って生きていくことはカオスの世界を生きていくコツなんじゃないか
と思います
これに対して人間は知性理性を発達させて明日の天気ぐらいは
予報できるようになりました
これは生存競争圧倒的に有利しました
だから皆さん幼稚園のときに友達100人だけどいまふたりになっちゃったよーなんて
ことはないんですよ
逆に明日の天気ぐらいちゃんと予報して予測して計画を立てないと人間社会の中で生き
ていけません
ただ困ったことに
野生の感性と人間の理性二世は往々にして矛盾します
野生の感性だけでは人間として生きていけない
だけど逆に知性と理性だけど生物として生きていけない
人間とはそもそも矛盾したものなんです
人間は生まれながらにして生物としてカオスの世界を生きていく
野生の本能を持っています
一方で人間は小学校中学校高校と人間社会の中で生きていくための
知恵と理性を学んできました
高校まで皆さんは過去の人類が蓄積した知識知恵を学んできたはずです
それはそれで非常に重要です
明日を生きていかなきゃならないからです
でもそれをそのままその先まで延長することはできないかもしれない
だからその先のことは
そこでおばで考えるしかない
しかもその時に
今の法則が成り立つ
自然性はないんです
だから
大学では
野生の本能を呼び覚ましてほしいんです
心の底の声を聞いてそれに従って行動できるようになってほしいんです
野生の本能にはいろいろあります
直感的に面白いと思うこと
夢中になること
逆に怠惰であることもそうだと思います
30年後若い皆さんは
我々が知らない問題を解決しなければなりません
その時何が役に立つかなんて誰も分からないんです
30年後に必要なのは野生の本能に従って報道する能力とその結果得た知識です
今役に立つと思っても
役に立たないと思っても
30年後にそれが役に立つ確率は大して変わりません
30年後だないが役に立つかなって誰も分かりません
でも面白いと思ってやることは
人に言われて嫌々やることに比べて10倍のことができます
だったら面白いと思った10倍のことをやっておけばですね
将来その中に役に立つものが入っている確率は10倍上がります
だから役に立つかどうかじゃなくて面白いかどうかでやることを決めるべきなんです
面白いという感覚は
多分生物がカオスの中を生きていく
ために必要な
野生の
本能です
その本能は
おそらく皆さんの高校までの勉強には邪魔だったから抑えてきたと思います
でもそのままでは生物として生きていくことができません
多分皆さんの本のまだ子供のままです
大学で一番大事なのは先生の言うことを聞くことじゃありません
自分自身の
心の底の声を聞くことです
そして
それに従って行動することです
大学はその練習ができる最後のチャンスです
30年後生きるのあなたがたです
即戦力はすぐに使えなくなります
いま輝いている必要はないんです問題は30年後なんです
今地味でいいんです
今は30年後に生きるための訓練をしてください
野生の本能を鍛えるんです
大学はそのためにあります
頑張ってください
[拍手]